und jetzt das heute schon mit heinz wolf
uns marietta slomka guten abend mit den
beziehungen deutschlands zur türkei ist
es derzeit ähnlich wie mit der beziehung
zu russland immer wenn man denkt jetzt
sei man am tiefpunkt angekommen geht es
noch weiter bergab
präsident erdogan will die botschafter
aus den westlichen staaten darunter
deutschland ausweisen lassen sie sollen
so schnell wie möglich zu persona non
grata erklärt werden also zu
unerwünschten personen
vielmehr beschimpfung geht eigentlich
nicht in der sprache der internationalen
diplomatie
wenn er diesen rausschmiss auch
tatsächlich durchzieht ist das eine
wirklich heftige eskalation glück weil
pott berichtet
vordergründig geht es um ihn ostmann
kavala regierungskritischer verleger und
mehr zehn seit vier jahren sitzt er in
türkischer haft ohne ein urteil auf den
fall angesprochen sagt er präsident
erdogan noch letzte woche beim besuch
von bundeskanzlerin merkel in istanbul
er könne sich da nicht einmischen die
türkische justiz sei unabhängig
doch diese türkische justiz missachtet
seit monaten die vom europäischen
gerichtshof für menschenrechte
geforderte freilassung covers dem
umsturzpläne und spionage vorgeworfen
werden bislang ohne beweise 10 westliche
botschafter darunter der deutschlands
frankreichs und der usa forderten letzte
woche die zügige freilassung covers das
war nicht nach erdogans geschmack die
botschafter wurden erst einbestellt
heute legte der präsident nach
diese botschafter sollen so schnell wie
möglich zu unerwünschten personen
erklärt werden ich habe dem
außenminister entsprechende anweisungen
erteilt
töne die wir seinen anhängern immer gut
ankommen die große türkei die von
niemandem zurückschreckt nur ein
peinliches
ablenkungsmanöver sagt der
oppositionsführer kilicdaroglu erdogan
stürzte das land in den abgrund den
menschen gehe es schlecht weil er die
wirtschaft zerstört habe hohe
arbeitslosigkeit 20 prozent inflation
und ein dramatischer kursverfall der
türkischen lira immer mehr türken müssen
den gürtel enger schnallen und sie
wenden sich ab vom präsidenten und
seiner partei der sucht jetzt wie so oft
in der vergangenheit den konflikt mit
dem westen um die nationalistischen
reihen hinter sich zu schließen die
nächste eskalation die der türkische
präsident seinen nato-partnern zumutet
[Musik]
newport in istanbul das ist aus dem
westen kritik an
menschenrechtsverletzungen in der türkei
gibt das ist ja nichts neues und die
türkische wirtschaft läuft auch schon
länger schlecht warum gerade jetzt diese
eskalation
weil es für erdogan auch außenpolitisch
in den kommenden monaten wesentlich
rauer zugehen wird also da wird in der
wind ins gesicht blasen beispiel usa da
konnte er mit trump ganz gut trump hatte
ihm karten ausgegeben für den einmarsch
in asien mit seinen türkischen truppen
beiden sieht das ganz anders da gibt es
erhebliche konflikte im moment ist da
hängt der haussegen schief beispiel
berlin mit bundeskanzlerin merkel konnte
man relativ gut zusammenarbeiten hat der
letzte woche noch mal gesagt mit der
neuen regierung ist das nicht so zu
erwarten da wird es sicher schärfere
töne richtungen ankara geben und der
europarat im fall kavala hat mit einem
rausschmiss der türkei gedroht ende des
jahres wenn bis dahin nicht die
freilassung kommt also da hat sich eine
menge geändert im außenpolitischen
verhältnis zur türkei und vielleicht
versucht erdogan hier sozusagen in die
vorhand zu kommen und selber zu agieren
denn dass ihm da ein scharfer wind ins
gesicht blasen wird es sicher ist dass
er erst einmal nur eine ankündigung dass
die botschafter ausgewiesen werden
sollen was schätzen sie wird er das
durchziehen
also es gibt auch heute abend hier bei
den türkischen kollegen im fernsehen und
in den zeitungen und internetmedien
spekulationen darüber ob es da noch eine
hintertür gibt wörtlich hat erdogan
gesagt wenn sie die türkei nicht
verstehen und nicht kennen dann werden
sie gehen müssen also irgendwie war das
noch so eine art hintertür aber
eigentlich waren das sehr scharfe töne
eine ziemliche eskalation und das war ja
vor laufenden kameras das fällt schwer
das zurückzunehmen im moment ist der
außenminister der das ganze umsetzen
soll noch in asien unterwegs der wird am
sonntagabend zurück erwartet also muss
man sehen ob montag dann zwischen
erdogan und außenminister davutoglu
entsprechende anweisungen laufen und was
das dann heißt für die botschafter käme
es dann würden wahrscheinlich die
partner die da ausgewiesen wurden auch
reagieren das heißt dann würde
wahrscheinlich auch der türkische
botschafter aus berlin ausgewiesen
werden danke lück für diese analysen
nach deutschland es häufen sich wieder
berichte über krone ausbrüche in
pflegeheimen das liegt zum einen an den
höheren instanzen die wir jetzt wieder
haben aber auch daran dass die im
wirkung bei alten menschen geringer ist
und wohl auch schneller nachlässt
deshalb sollen sich senioren jetzt ja
auch ein dringend eine dritte spritze
geben lassen was bei diesen berichten
über ausbrüche in senioreneinrichtungen
allerdings auch auffällt dass es immer
noch ungeimpft das pflegepersonal gibt
ausgerechnet dort wo der kontakt zu
besonders gefährdeten menschen so eng
ist auch deshalb fordern
patientenschützer für
senioreneinrichtungen eine tägliche
testpflicht unabhängig vom impfstatus
derweil die zahlen weiter steigen
dalian tag berichtet
1000 impfdosen an einem tag das ziel der
impfkampagne heute in der stuttgarter
innenstadt impfen gegen die wieder
steigenden infektionszahlen die sieben
tage inzidenz ist wieder dreistellig und
liegt aktuell bei genau 100 trotzdem
meint der gesundheitsminister dass wir
dank dieser vielen impfungen und das
robert-koch-institut sagt für geimpfte
ist das risiko moderat jetzt eben auch
diesen ausnahmezustand hin zu einem
zustand besonderer vorsicht verlassen
können den nächsten schritt gehen können
ab ende november also hin zu einem
zustand der vorsicht wenn es nach sparen
geht bei 66 prozent vollständig
geimpften viel zu wenig um die neue
welle zu brechen sagen virologen die
mehrheit der länder chefinnen und chefs
fordern einen bundesweit einheitlichen
rechtsrahmen deutlichere kritik an
spahns vorstoß vom spd
gesundheitsexperten die perspektive dass
die lage einmal endet epidemische lage
zu ende kommt die muss es natürlich
geben aber ich sage mir jesus kein guter
moment dafür denn wir haben jetzt
steigende fallzahlen wir haben mehr
krankenhauseinweisungen wir haben mehr
patient auf der intensivstation und die
impfrate stagniert da kommen wir auch
nicht weiter da ist es jetzt kaum zu
vermitteln auch nicht den
intensivmediziner innern und dem
krankenhauspersonal schon jetzt kommen
die kliniken an ihre kapazitätsgrenzen
aktuell sind weniger intensiv betten
frei als noch zur spitze der dritten
welle ende april
wir haben innerhalb eines jahres
ungefähr 5000 intensivbetten die wir
nicht mehr betreiben können aufgrund des
pflege mangels der unterschied führt
jetzt dazu dass wir heute unter 1000
freie betten für beatmungspatienten
haben das ist der niedrigste punkt den
wir insgesamt seit 18 monaten gesehen
haben eine situation die in manchen
regionen schon jetzt spürbar ist
besonders dort wo die impfquote niedrig
und die neuinfektionen hoch sind
mehr hintergründe und videos rund um
corona gibt es bei uns wie immer online
auf zdf heute mit den crooner thema gibt
es jetzt auch erstmal den nachrichten
noch weiter hans in österreich bringt
die regierung weitere mögliche corona
maßnahmen auf den weg
erst vor einigen tagen wurde eine 3g
regel für viele beschäftigte an ihrem
arbeitsplatz angekündigt jetzt sorgt die
bundes künstler schallenberg dass bei
einer dramatischen verschärfung der lage
auf den intensivstationen
ungeschützte menschen mit ausgangs
beschränkungen rechnen müssten eine lok
dann für geimpfte und genesene schlosser
aus
rund ein halbes jahr vor der
parlamentswahl in ungarn gab es dort
heute am nationalfeiertag zwei große
kundgebungen ministerpräsident orban
sprach zum wahlkampfauftakt in budapest
vor anhängern und kritisierte die ihnen
deren institutionen würden den bürgern
ungarns vorschreiben wollen wie sie zu
leben hätten etwa zwei kilometer
entfernt die kundgebung der opposition
um ihren parteilosen spitzenkandidaten
markus orf die sechs oppositionsparteien
auf weiterhin geschlossenheit zu zeigen
um orban abzulösen
das us militär hat nach eigenen angaben
im nordwesten syriens ein führendes
mitglied der terrororganisation al kaida
getötet
abdul hamid al mada soll bei einem
drohnenangriff ums leben gekommen
erklärte ein armeesprecher
er sagte al kaida nutze syrien als basis
für bedrohungen die nach syrien in den
irak und darüber hinaus reichten vor
zwei tagen war im süden syriens ein
luftwaffen stützpunkt angegriffen worden
die us geführte anti es koalition nutzt
in italien hat ein prozess gegen den
früheren innenminister salvini begonnen
wieder blockade eines flüchtlingsschiffs
die staatsanwaltschaft wirft ihm
freiheitsberaubung und amtsmissbrauch
vor im august 2009 10 lag das
rettungsschiff open arms mit mehr als
140 migranten von lampedusa durfte aber
tagelang nicht einlaufen nach einer
anordnung der italienischen
staatsanwaltschaft konnte das schiff am
ende anlegen
auf der kanaren insel la palma kommt der
vulkan auch nach über vier wochen nicht
zur ruhe die heiße lava breitet sich im
westen der insel immer weiter aus den
bewohnern la palmas machen zudem er
neben und aschewolken zu schaffen
wissenschaftlern zufolge könnte der
ausbruch noch monate dauern
das ist ein regierungswechsel gibt ist
in der demokratie ja das normalste von
der welt erst recht wenn eine partei 16
jahre lang kanzlerin oder kanzler stellt
doch für die cdu herrscht jetzt
natürlich trotzdem
ausnahmezustand nicht mehr zu regieren
mit der oppositionsrolle klar zu kommen
und sich neu aufzustellen um künftig
wieder wahlen gewinnen zu können das ist
für viele in der partei jetzt erstmal
ein schmerzlicher prozess
manche wirken immer noch gegen
schockstarre andere entwickeln eine art
hyperaktivismus und wieder andere
überlegen wie sie am ehesten zum
krisengewinnler werden können in
nordrhein westfalen heimat des
glücklosen kanzlerkandidaten hat die cdu
zumindest ihre personalfrage geklärt und
es damit schon mal einen schritt weiter
als die bundesebene
thomas münten berichtet
so funktioniert politik hatte
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
noch bis zur wahl demonstrativ seinen
parteichef armin laschet unterstützt
suchte er heute genau so demonstrativ
die nähe zu verkehrsminister hendrik
wüst der wird mit 98,3 prozent zum
nachfolger des glücklosen armin laschet
als landesvorsitzender gewählt und macht
gleich klar die zeit der grabenkämpfe in
der union muss jetzt enden
leute wir haben die bundestagswahl
verloren und so wie es aussieht haben
wir auch die regierungsbeteiligung
verloren wir dürfen aber nicht noch
anstand mitnehmen und haltung verlieren
liebe freundinnen und freunde in der
union muss wieder gelten haltung stadt
spaltung
armin laschet wäre lieber als wahlsieger
im bund gegangen jetzt hat der rückzug
einen faden beigeschmack die man
loswerden muss finden die delegierten
das ist nicht berlin das nrw haben wir
eine gute politik gemacht seit
viereinhalb jahren ich treffe ich
menschen wissen das und hat die kunst
wird ein sehr guter ministerpräsident
ich denke mal generationenwechsel in
dieser dieser zeit ist jetzt sicherlich
angebracht und gut und so dass wir uns
mit einer jungen mannschaft
aufstellen können wobei wir ja nicht nur
junge leute in den künftigen
landesvorstand wählen sondern auch
erfahrene alte recken verrechnung armin
laschet wird mit minutenlangem applaus
empfangen badet in der anerkennung und
ist sichtlich entspannt in seiner rede
geht es um erfolge im land um falsche
freunde und indirekt auch um die enns
sparen wenn ich jetzt lese wieder manche
als kandidatin des bundes vorsitzes
sicht präsentieren und sein ist die
größte krise der cdu seit 1945 oder
ähnliches naja das inspiriert überhaupt
kein wähler wieder cdu zu wählen all das
wird wirklich ja unsinn fünf minuten
standing ovations für den scheidenden
ministerpräsidenten dann der
generationswechsel von dem hier alles
sprechen doch von acht
vorstandsmitgliedern behalten fünf ihre
posten ist dass der verkündete neuanfang
ich denke das ist ein echter aufbruch
gewesen für die cdu und hoffentlich
ausgehend von nordrhein westfalen dann
auch wieder für und ich würde sagen das
alter an sich das kriterium ist ich
glaube der neue vorsitzende braucht
viele fähigkeiten und das einfach allein
ist nicht entscheidend
am mittwoch will sich hendrik wüst im
landtag zum ministerpräsidenten von
nordrhein westfalen wählen lassen die
schwarz gelbe regierungskoalition hat
nur eine stimme mehrheit sollte das
nicht im ersten wahlgang gelingen ist
wüst schon zum start beschädigt
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten immer ohne gewähr 1
10 19 22 26 28 superzahl 2 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 6
die wetteraussichten für morgen nach
nebelauflösung gibt es viel sonne im
nordosten halten sich anfangs auch noch
einige wolken bei einem im norden
lebhaften südwind werden 10 bis 16 grad
erreicht die weiteren aussichten am
montag können sich nebel und hochnebel
teils länger halten am dienstag wird es
in der westhälfte etwas regnen am
mittwoch bleibt es bei sonne und nebel
wieder trocken was man uns gleich gibt's
aktuellen sportstudio weiter und danach
so gegen 0.25 gibt es dann die nächste
heute express hat uns morgen wieder bis
dahin wieder so
[Musik]